should we have a bullet World
Championship well it depends what that
is because if it's one zero with no
increment then yeah it's going to be
such a mess that you'll never be able to
sort out all the disputes and complaints
and and so on if it's like 1 minute with
1 second increment it's still going to
be a mess but because one second
increment over the board isn't too much
maybe like two seconds two second
increment I don't know if that's splitz
or bullet but um it's an idea I wouldn't
take it too seriously but I would
probably have fun participating in an
event like that yeah maybe that's the
future of Chess let's
see like the general person how what
would your recommendation for me be to
improve get better at Blitz I would say
practice is very important and uh
tactical awareness is the most important
thing in Blitz uh I would say two things
are definitely like top of the list the
first is tactical awareness and the
second is going to be being comfortable
in the positions you play so having a
repertoire where you know what you're
doing is is going to be very important
as well